[Música]
un pequeño rincón de francia perdido en
el océano índico cubierta de volcanes y
bosques exuberantes la isla de la
reunión ofrece paisajes que cortan la
respiración en el corazón de la isla ma
fat concentra toda esa belleza salvaje
en ese gigantesco pnv y el teatro
natural situado a 1600 metros de altura
viven literalmente aislados del mundo
700 habitantes hasta más sólo se puede
llegar a pie por senderos escarpados o
por el aire aquí el cartero aterriza
siempre en helicóptero
tal vez mis colegas están un poco
celosos por el helicóptero utilizo con
frecuencia entonces estoy acostumbrado
el cartero de mapa está sale del litoral
con las primeras luces del día desde el
cielo se perciben unos islotes los
caseríos que pueblan el circo tras el
aterrizaje empieza la maratón de rain
cloud 615 kilómetros de caminata para
entregar las noticias en mapa de rené
conoce a los habitantes de aquí por ello
la confianza reina no en los buzones
y
como está muy cansado parís es la
profesora de mapat se encarga de 12
alumnos
los de primero y segundo ya leyeron toda
la historia tour listo una sola clase
pero con varios cursos desde preescolar
hasta cuarto de primaria
yo solamente superviso si no estoy
disponible los pequeños acuden a los
grandes hay que estar atento a todo es
efectivo poder aprender tanto con un
niño como con un adulto
pronto que entrará a la secundaria pero
aquí no hay entonces como todos los
adolescentes demás fate tendrá que ir a
un internado en la costa
el colegio aquí es un pequeño paraíso
del que uno no quisiera irse todo bien
muy bien estuvieron muy tranquilos que
bueno pero este pequeño paraíso sigue
siendo una montaña y la vida aquí no es
tan fácil para la ida nos demoramos
entre 25 minutos y media hora todas las
mañanas subiendo siempre es un poco
inclina de regreso en su casa sandrine
prepara la especialidad de la isla el
hockey y con salchichas pero aquí el
abastecimiento es complicado hay que
hacer las compras en el litoral y luego
pagar 300 euros de transporte aéreo para
recibirlas y todas las tareas cotidianas
requieren de organización preferimos
cocinar con estufa de leña el gas es
caro y además hay que traerlo hasta acá
aquí no hay ni supermercado ni hospital
para cuidar la salud de los locales
nadie es enfermera se instaló hace poco
en la clínica del caserío de cayena
estetoscopio y tensiómetro en la maleta
todos los días se pone sus zapatos de
caminar para ir a ver a los habitantes
entre dos pacientes a veces me demoro
una hora y media o dos horas caminando
para ir de una casa a otra en esas zonas
aisladas hay que estar particularmente
alerta sobre todo con las personas de
mayor edad
[Música]
pero tienes que hacerte otro examen
adicional eso fue lo que dijo el médico
y dijo que no debías esforzarte
demasiado al menos hasta el examen la
relación es más cercana
uno aprende muchas cosas sobre el
paciente de manera general
[Música]
en los senderos la enfermera se
encuentra todos los días con caminantes
el turismo es la principal fuente de
ingresos de la isla
[Música]
mira camps que lindo con salud
camine vive en la reunión decidió
mostrarle más falta a su amiga leticia
que viene de estrasburgo es maravilloso
es la primera vez que vengo a la reunión
era uno de los lugares que realmente
quería conocer no estoy decepcionado
aquí uno está por fuera del tiempo no me
arrepiento para nada
si habitará en uno tiene la impresión de
estar de viaje para mí que vivo una
reunión es como irme del lugar más fácil
no hay nada igual
es un lugar totalmente atípico muy
revitalizante existen nuevos ojos
voy a tomar una foto
alrededor de 100.000 visitantes recorren
más fat cada año
[Música]